you may recognize actor Steven hug from
his roles on the walking dead the tick
or the new snowpiercer series in that
show he plays spike a convicted robber
who escapes custody and now leaves the
tale of the titular train serving as a
warrior of lower-class passengers or
maybe just maybe you know him from the
wildly popular video game Grand Theft
Auto 5 in which he's a voice and motion
captured inspiration behind the deranged
Trevor Phillips I find your t-shirt more
than a little offensive there's one
thing I cannot stand
it's post-ironic tipsters that 2013 role
effectively launched ogz career and he's
been climbing up the hollywood ladder
ever since for the three of you who
haven't played GTA 5 the
action-adventure title follows three
career criminals as they well commit
crimes these adventures typically
involve gunfire graphic violence and car
chases the game is sold over 130 million
copies across various platforms and
generated more than six billion dollars
in revenue in total the entire GTA
franchise which rockstar games launched
in 1997 includes more than eleven
standalone games many of which have been
bona fide cultural blockbusters it's one
of the most successful video game series
in history thanks in large part to gta5
tastic in an exclusive interview with
looper I'll go open up about what he
thinks about the franchise his feelings
about his role as Trevor and what he
knows about the next installment of the
game now before we begin let us ask you
a question what does a former Air Force
pilot in training turn psychopathy
career criminal have to do with a
good-natured saturweeeeen moisture
farmer what is it
father's light sabre this is the weapon
of a Jedi Knight well not a whole lot
but Steve odds of a good points you see
the enormous popularity of grand theft
auto 5 has left Arg in a unique position
despite a prolific career in television
his ultraviolent role in the video game
Garner's him the most attention he
explained it's sort of like Mark Hamill
is forever Luke Skywalker I might
forever have this Trevor grand theft
auto thing which listen I'm proud of it
it doesn't bug me because it was work I
enjoyed well Argus never played the game
he says-- portraying a motion-capture
carrots it was a blast
he tells looper be a theatre film or TV
the world
the words and that's your job as an
actor to create these characters and say
these words but it's just a technique
that differs with motion capture so it
was sure fun to do this motion capture
and to create again this rather crazy
impulsive character that I had a blast
doing it it was like seven years ago but
it was fun a lot of fun
aaaghh also shares a portraying Trevor
and the grand theft auto universe has
generated the largest fan base of the
vollis characters though he does have a
legion of Walking Dead enthusiasts
behind him as well thanks his role as
Simon the right-hand man to Jeffrey Dean
Morgan sneakin it's time to do some
proper slaughtering on a worldwide scale
however there's a clear winner
aaaggghhh dished it would probably be
GTA and then Walking Dead but certainly
globally Grand Theft Auto it's pretty
crazy
I've been all over the world China
Brazil Europe Canada the Philippines
I've been a lot of places and they're a
sponsor Grand Theft Auto is still crazy
that's a pretty global crazy thing it's
really nuts however just because our
contribute said to the success of gta5
doesn't mean he knows anything about the
next installment of the video game
franchise he explained bluntly I don't
know actors are the last to know
anything you want to know anything about
any production well maybe another motion
capture go talk to hair and makeup or
the special effects team because they
have to budget the entire season I spoke
at the Vancouver acting school or film
school and they asked what's your advice
for young actors I said the first day be
friends with hair and makeup because
that's how you're going to know where
your characters going and what you're
doing because they know everything still
arc speculates that his character Trevor
probably won't be back though he can't
say anything with complete confidence
considering he hasn't kept up with the
Grand Theft Auto series he admits I
don't follow the video games I don't
know what they do so I'm still not in
that world I have no idea I don't think
they've bring characters back ever they
all seem to be one offs and he'd be
right more or less GTA isn't known for
bringing characters back too often at
least not for very long
though augs Trevor may not pop up in
Grand Theft Auto 6 fans of the actor can
still see his face on screen just in a
different medium like we mentioned that
the starts hug currently stars on TNT
snowpiercer series and though his role
in season 1 is any recurring capacity
the actor will fortunately become a
series regular in season 2 so whether
you know him from TV or just the games
you play on your TV
certainly haven't seen the last of
Stephen hog check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies TV
shows and video games are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]